siempre han formado parte del paisaje
pero actualmente los pescadores
artesanales de mbour uno de los puertos
más grandes de senegal que enfrentan un
futuro incierto ibrahim de 36 años va de
regreso a casa y como es habitual la
pesca no salió bien
sólo atrapé esto hoy
antes a 7 u 8 kilómetros de la costa
teníamos muchos peces hoy aunque nos
alejemos 30 kilómetros no pescamos casi
nada la pesca ya no es rentable
la sobrepesca industrial ha pasado
factura los grandes pescadores de mbour
acusan a los grandes barcos de arrastre
extranjeros de vaciar el mar algunos
dicen que no tienen más remedio que
cambiar de oficio para mata el tiempo
con algunos amigos todos pescadores
retirados como el
vendimos el mar a barcos extranjeros
sólo nos dejan migajas la única solución
que nos queda a nosotros que conocemos
bien el océano es intentar cruzar al
grupo manteniéndola up to live in hyde
conoce bien la angustia de los hombres
de mbour este pescador trabaja en
estrecha colaboración con las
comunidades locales hoy hace un llamado
a las autoridades para que garanticen
una gestión sostenible de la pesca
verdad abrir esas cajas fui maestro mira
esas cajas si hubiera peces estas cajas
estarían llenas de arán estos barcos
están raspando el fondo marino de los
océanos de senegal y de los países
vecinos llevando de alimentos a millones
de personas debemos olvidar que es la
pesca artesanal la que alimenta a los
senegaleses en las regiones no costeras
pero también a los países vecinos como
benin burkina faso malí y otros los
pescadores no son los únicos preocupados
por el agotamiento de los recursos
pesqueros las pescaderías y las mujeres
que venden y procesan pescado también
son víctimas colaterales en senegal
según cifras oficiales el 20 por ciento
de la población vive directa o
indirectamente de la industria pesquera